Speaker 1: Let's go next to Daniel from Taiwan.
Daniel, welcome.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, how are you?
I'm doing well.
I was just I mean, what would you tell somebody
that's in Taiwan that's increasingly maybe
concerned about being invaded by an authoritarian
regime that shall not be named?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I would be.
I would be very, very much sensitive to what
what may become a precarious situation.
I mean, listen, I said weeks ago, I think
China's paying attention to what's happening
in Russia and Ukraine to see what is Russia
allowed to get away with.
And as a result, what might China be allowed
to get away with when it comes to Taiwan?
I am.
I don't want to say I'm expecting aggression,
but I am.
Thinking it's quite plausible that there will
be aggression towards Taiwan from China, so
I don't know, I mean, I would I would be paying
attention to what local government is saying.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I mean, there's I mean, there's
a couple of things that I'd like to say about
this.
I did send you an email about this, I wrote.
I mean, I'm sure you get a lot of emails,
so it's probably just lost in the weeds there.
But I don't like the I don't like the fact
that China gets to have their, you know, state
run media and propaganda channels on Western
social media like Facebook, Twitter, Instagram.
They have, you know, plenty of YouTube channels
just spreading their propaganda.
And you know, I just checked on Facebook,
only one of their state run media channels,
just one they have many and just one has over
a million and 100 million followers on Facebook.
Hmm.
And and obviously.
They're not allowed to have, you know, any
media channels that they don't approve of
over there.
So I just see that as like this unfair balance
to where they get to very successfully spread
the propaganda outside their borders, but
not the other way or not received the other
way around.
That's a fair criticism.
Yeah.
And it really it really affects the conversation
publicly.
And I just don't I just don't like that.
I don't want to take up too much time.
But I also just like to say that the People's
Republic of China, which is their official
name, has never governed Taiwan in any century,
decade, year, month, week, day, hour, minute,
second in history.
It's never happened before.
And I would I send you an email suggesting
an expert on the topic they maybe have on
the show?
Speaker 1: OK.
All right, Daniel from Taiwan.
Thank you.
You've said it all.
Correction Wolf Blitzer reported extensively
from Ashkelon, but he was actually born in
Germany.
So I want to make sure that I clarify that
just in the interest of clarity this evening.